just want to welcome everyone to the
data science hanging out
i know most of you have been here before
but if this is your first time it's a
open space for current and aspiring data
science leaders to just connect and chat
about some of the more human-centric
questions around data science leadership
we really want to create a space where
everybody can participate and want to
hear from everyone
so there's three ways that you can ask
questions
you can jump in live i can pass you the
the fake microphone
and put questions in the chat
and then we also have a slider link
where you could ask anonymous questions
too
and rob will help me by sharing that in
the chat window right now
but this will be recorded and shared up
to youtube as well for anybody that
missed it today so just want to make
sure i let everybody know that
zoom should tell you that when you're
you're joining as well
but i'm so excited to be joined by my
co-host for today and friend on linkedin
i know we haven't met yet in person but
i'd like to introduce you to edgar gallo
chief data officer at daimler trucks
north america
edgar could i turn it over to you to
have you introduce yourself and some of
the work that you do on your team
thank you very much yes absolutely uh
very excited to be here i've been
attending uh for for a few weeks now and
months i can say
super uh interesting topics uh i hope i
meet the caliber of the other co-hosts
you have had
um big juice to feel here but
i've over over the time i've learned
people are very welcoming and warm so
my background i've been with our company
for almost 15 years now
i started with them in finance and
controlling in a very quantitative like
role
um
from there i move into a role where we
a team we have in our company it's kind
of unique in that it is a
an internal consulting team
and what we do is we focus on process
improvement process engineering um
load balancing things about nature and
and back when i joined we had
the two areas of focus together one of
them was our area in manufacturing in
our area on the non-assembly uh space if
you will uh you know processes like
accounting and hiring things of that
nature
and it was in that um
let's say play space where uh
i did
a lot of the analytics that were not so
much driven by my interest but the
interest of others which which it was
really really key for me to
understand and really
tag along into what uh back in the day
with the background in econometrics and
stats i i was able to recognize the data
science
so
um i i run a team of very curious and
inquisitive people that were split
between the east coast and the west
coast were run projects all over the
place
super fun
but something i learned over time is
that the the
ability to measure not only their
satisfaction with their work
um asking are we moving the needle or
not with all the time we're spending in
in this analysis but also
the stakeholder satisfaction
right are they seeing a difference that
is measurable it was really closely
connected to the ability to get data
from the processes
and that's where i had the aha moment
where
we really needed to move into more
data-centric focus
so i pitched it to my boss to pitch it
to their bosses who pitch it to you know
there's always more bosses but they all
were receptive of the fact that uh we
really weren't adding any more head
count
and we had spent about
i wouldn't say the better part of three
months
studying the need of the company right
doing this market research internally if
you will
to where we had found a really nice gap
that we could fit
and also
a training let's say
the training method
what do we need to get from
really uh smart people to practicing
data scientists so those were the two
outcomes of these three month-long
process
and as a result of that we started a
team of data scientists that
started working for the company
and as of november of last year i moved
into the chief data office role
again that's time you know
doing the laundry with the data
scientists i realized the pattern and
that was
that um
for the first or the early days of our
uh let's see erratic systems
most of our projects were
not so much data science projects but
the data engineering process where's the
data how can we get it how can we make
sure it's reliable trust of all things
of that nature
so that really piqued my interest into
the whole world of uh governance and
access management and data management
and that's what i do now for for diamond
trucks in north america
that's awesome thank you so much for
that introduction edgar and i know you
just touched upon
that training piece a little bit and
building up that team and i think that
that was something we were talking about
in a linkedin post maybe a few months
ago
but i think it'd be
awesome to hear a little bit more about
how you went through that process and i
know you mentioned like a buddy system
before
between
new
data scientists and existing ones
but we'd love to just dive into that a
little bit
yeah absolutely so um
when i was hiring for this team of
consultants i really didn't focus on a
specific
background i more so have always focused
on
um
i'm infamous for making up words so i i
focus on team get a longness
right so i try to get different
personalities
that will get the best out of each other
when i put them to work together
so with with that in mind i ended up
with people from accounting people from
engineering people from
really people with no
with real life work education versus a
specific degree or things of that nature
so
we had a really diverse team in that
sense and i noticed i was very
successful
for the consulting piece
so when we started looking at the
uh uh stacking up the data science piece
it was a little more challenging in that
um
we have to have some rigor to the
training right so when we were doing the
research uh part of the uh of the pitch
to set up the group
um
we went out and said okay what would it
be that we needed to do from a
quantitative side but also from the soft
skill side
and it really validated that we could
needed to continue having this
introvert and extrovert balance if you
will
because the extroverts were really good
at explaining to others the black box
and introverts were really really good
at creating this black box
so
that was kind of the the beginning of of
setting up the body system
um but then really the the one of the uh
let's say
value propositions for for the team to
be
created was
um how do we disseminate this in in a
company that it's trying and trying and
having really advanced engineering in
some pockets
where we're creating trucks that are you
know
now powered by electricity and batteries
and renewables
trucks that can drive themselves
but in the other hand how do we bring
the rest of our company
um up in this in this layer of of
upskilling right so that that portion
was also a
a a value prop element where we said
look
we're not only going to create training
for ourselves we're going to find ways
to disseminate this knowledge
so that was one of the
pieces where we said anytime we engage
with a department in the business
we want to have a body system we want to
make sure that we start
where the driver
and our clients are in the back seat
eventually they choose somebody that
gets along with this and put them in the
passenger side so we can start creating
more
proliferation of the understanding of
the business knowledge and how you apply
the data science techniques
until eventually we swap and they are
driving the project through when they
see it to completion with without
coaching
i like that you're using the driving
analogies there from daimler
um so
for that i'm waiting for a few questions
to come in so i want to just dive into
this a little bit more but for that
training
what did that look like or
did you use outside
tools or did you just identify a few
like experts internally
so so just like i make up words i'm
super thrifty and i'm always trying to
have like the least resistance from the
the pros i have to approve anything i
pitch right super uh shoestring budget
right
um so we we looked at where most people
were coming from and this is for
specifically for those that were going
to join the team
and most people have a certain
content of
playing along with excel and you know do
some data mining so we focus on what
most people know now
and then we focus on the um actually the
coursera um
data science certification so we took
that as the backbone of our training
and then we just did this little spider
chart to see how far people were
away from it
and once we knew we were the primary
targets of training
we looked at either partnering with um
sorry i mean
either partnering with uh coursera or
linkedin learning or a couple of other
places where we had some
corporate licenses and affiliations
we ended up working with a company i
think out of the uk um
[Music]
and they had really specific
training for things we wanted to learn
how to use like
altera designer altera server uh you
know statistics
things things along that nature but they
were all web consumed and we managed to
get a great deal through our indirect
procurement team that did wonderful
negotiation for us and and that was not
only for us
but we were able to negotiate licenses
for those that were joining us in
projects from the business
great thank you i see a few questions
coming in um
around some of the work that your team's
doing and i think it's also awesome to
get this feedback on or to understand
like the kinds of problems that your
team is solving
and one is at daimler trucks north
america how do you approach service
customer retention
so trucks going to their maintenance
inspections from a data science
perspective
that's a very interesting point i think
we're trying to um
we're trying two things right we're
trying to evaluate and this is kind of
an interesting quandary because
we make the trucks
and our partner dealer base sells to
trucks
so every dealer is their own
business right we don't own all those
dealers just like you hear about
for this and fourth of ad and you know
they're all local businesses
so while you can suggest some best
practices you can't impose how they're
going to conduct a business
so a lot of what we do is partner with
them to develop technology to develop
best practices
um just like we have for internally we
have a team that goes out there and
helps them with assessments and
and finds the opportunities but then
what we do with with the technology
piece is
we're working on the best methods to
identify
what's wrong with the truck ahead of
time for example
right predictive maintenance things
about nature so we have a team of data
scientists that works under the big data
group
um
that is working on um you know
developing these algorithms that can
help any person that manages you know
thousands of trucks
to know how to best choose a location
for service
you know find out if that location has
already
the parts that are needed
um we're even looking at some um
quite
futuristic aspects of
how can the truck broker this whole
thing on its own
without intervention from a human and
all of that is hinging on the right
algorithms the trust with the customer
the right data set and and the right
data governance on it
um i i wish i could share a lot more but
some of the things you know are kind of
edge on on how it work and what would
work but it it in the whole thing is
a dealer has base and and they need to
use these bases rapidly as they can
so the anything we can do to expedite
what goes into the bay to be ready to be
diagnosed
100 percent
and parts being there and get it out of
the bay as soon as it can it's no
different than the pursuit of an f1 pit
stop
fast fast fast
and just let us know if there's any
questions
that you can't answer too um but the
next one that someone asked anonymously
was have you used data science for truck
configurations
like the low oh it's a fascinating topic
it's a fascinating topic um
i haven't but i know that we are looking
at how do we make that easier the the
the biggest challenge with our business
is that we don't make trucks like cars
are made in that you have a black one
and a blue one and they change very
little between one and the other
really trucks are completely different
trucks are made from two frame rails and
then you start bolting cross members and
then you
you measure where you want your axles
and all of these measurements create
very unique very particular
um
specific trucks and the one that follows
it is not done because there's a hundred
of them that are should be made the same
it's it's mostly a balancing of the
factory and customer requirements and
when they need it
so
while we have tried that uh and we are
doing that um it's really uh
it's really ultimately in my in my
opinion it's really ultimately a
a balancing act between the art of
building a truck and designing and
speccing
which uh our partners have a huge deal
of pride
on building the truck for their
customers that's sitting right there
with them
and and trying to make more kind of
vanilla packaging of trucks so
it can be a it can be kind of a it's a
difficult thing to balance i want to say
well while you can have everything push
automatically
and just say i want a blue like i was
playing earlier with a configuration for
a maverick i don't know why i really
want
um
even that the permutations are small and
and and i could just only imagine what
would take me to build a truck that i
could move the axles on
based on
formulas that we have to meet for for
example bridge weight capacity
differences in massachusetts in oregon
in washington and if the trust's going
to go across basically all states at any
point in time they ought to meet those
so it's kind of challenging to just say
hey this size it all but there are some
efforts on improving
configuration
in in ease of use and and improving of
course you know potentially
profitability of a package versus
another
thank you
so maybe
shifting gears just a little bit for a
second here i know you you mentioned
that you were at daimler for
maybe about 14 years um
and i'd love to just hear
maybe any advice that you have for
growing within the organization or
getting from where you you started to
chief data officer
for people who are aspiring leaders on
the call too
it's um
it's a very interesting thing because
ever since i joined i don't know if it
was about
um surviving right i joined and then the
greater session hits and everything was
terrible around the world
so we survived and we survived by being
cohesive
by helping out beyond our need right i
might have been in finance but if a peer
of mine needed help in purchasing or
supply chain or you know we just did it
and then eventually we had
a group of people come together into a a
cross-functional team
where we were reassessing every single
thing
from what is the impact of uh you know
moving printers far away so people don't
print or for it double-sided everything
we needed to do so we really built a
really strong community of
of purpose-driven people
and that really kind of uh really just
kind of stuck with me like
if if i continue doing purposes and work
you know i get exposed to more and more
opportunities
yes it's more work yes we have longer
days
uh uh it it it requires some trade-offs
but in the end
you develop this street cred of of you
know go-to kind of people and and and it
just kind of follows you right so when i
move from finance to
the internal consulting group
some peers were really happy so managers
were really happy some other work no why
are you moving what did we do kind of
thing right eventually everyone
understands that you're moving to build
up a career and get to know the business
but really it was about uh what else can
i do for you sort of thing
in in in the balancing act between
well now you are my doormat versus i'm
i'm a guy that can help but not do
everything for you right that was that
was and those were some of my lessons
learned where you're like
wait a minute i'm the only one left
everybody left and i was helping them
and now it's my job so
i fell a couple times but learned quick
and kept doing that and fine tuning the
balance between i can help you versus
i'll do it for you
that was recognized by my now boss the
cio and
i remember when he came
first you know about a year into it he
kept saying when are you coming to our
team when are you coming to a t
and uh
and eventually you know the role came
out and i thought you know what i could
make a difference here on on when it
comes to the data management and the
the governance piece and and uh
implementing our policy so
i took a swing and i got the job
that's great thank you and
when you talk about that time where you
were just answering all these questions
and just kind of helping out any team
how did you
kind of come up with what were the
questions that people had out of the
from the business or how did you collect
those
so i don't know maybe it's the esl thing
right i always double check what i'm
understanding
and and i and i asked do you mean this
or you mean that or
um instead of i heard somebody say the
other really really well instead of just
giving them
uh what they're asking for
ask what they're trying to answer
because sometimes they come to you say
hey can you give me the roi on moving
this supplier from here to there
and you can just give them that or find
out more contextually what are they
pursuing if they're pursuing an answer
to
uh you know either increase increase
profitability or reduce costs or just
flat out make a decision for a
purchasing agent or things like that
maybe just scratching a little bit past
the surface and understand contextually
thank you that's really helpful
and i got that scary signal of internet
unstable so please let me know if
anything happens tori i see you just
asked a question in the chat if you'd
want to
ask that live too oh sure hey edgar hi
i heard that you said that you report to
the cio
and i was interested in your thoughts
about data being within it
versus i've seen a trend of
taking the chief data officer and making
it its own like making that area its own
that reports to the ceo
i was just curious what your thoughts
are where you think that's going and how
it's worked the pros and cons
i i think um yes i've seen the same and
it's uh
it's an interesting path in that um
i think it's a spectrum of maturity
right and and
i tell you we're we're a very
traditional business we're an industrial
um
our focus has been on making the best
trucks the most reliable trucks forever
we have
an extremely smart group of engineers
that can do calculations over and over
and over
but i think we're finally getting into
understanding that
those calculations eventually
you know let's say fill the bin
and they need to go somewhere but they
can't just go away because our trucks
last a long time so we have a commitment
to our customers and when we're
troubleshooting a truck that's 10 15 20
years old
those calculations matter
so now we're slowly creeping into the
data management topic right which uh
forever has been in it
but
the cool thing about it is that my boss
is not traditional i see cio
he's the cio that is
proactive
let's say business a business maker if
you will in that he understands that
uh for the longest time the accumulation
of data is a good thing if you know how
to use it or it's a bad thing if you
don't know how to take care of it and
curate it
so i would say at the moment for the
maturity spectrum and where we are as a
company it's it's working really well
for us because
uh his understanding of it is leading
edge i would say so he's a really good
broker of support with our board
now um
i know that as the board understands
more and more what about the risks and
the benefits then we talk about
ransomware and the under risks and you
know information security and
information access management
and then we have more and more uh let's
say regulations and you know right to
repair ccpa and you name it right
those topics
are are taking kind of a
space of their own and that's where
with the the cio's uh support on it
the board realizes more and more that
that cdo is a it's an important role in
that
somebody's got to
be doing traffic control beyond the
business that we traditionally support
beyond the design beyond the improvement
beyond the innovation on the product
so i i don't know if i see a future for
us in which the cdo would report
directly to the ceo
but definitely i i see a a much more
ingrained and deeply rooted um
relationship
and i hope that answer your questions
that kind of went on yeah that was no
that was really interesting
one other question i have oh you have
other questions
well ask this and if you have time um
i've seen also it's been interesting the
not everybody understands data science
and data and
the structure of how do you
what do you think of like the cdo is it
is the cdo and that office over
everything data including data
governance and modeling and like there
it's a big area and it's explosive so
how do you
handle a good structure to allow that
stuff to work cohesively
so i think um
most people give answers related to how
many people you have what type of people
you have
the people topic is incredibly
challenging right now so
um i was very fortunate to hire real
good people um you know when i had
postings but i hear my fears over and
over you know losing people people
moving this and that
so the the best way to tackle this at
the moment is just kind of being johnny
on the spot where it's a whether it's a
formal conversation or it's an informal
conversation right um i remember we were
working on onboarding a team of external
providers and they were deploying this
software
and i was just there because somebody
thought oh maybe you know
knucklehead needs to be here so i didn't
see the music
so they start pitching all this stuff
about
ai and this and that and the other so i
go hey for for instance i love your ai
approach and i love that you say it's
going to like flip it over and make it
work and it's going to be done by itself
but you're talking about an application
that's really close to an nlp
application which is only as good as
your dictionary so
how long is it going to take you to get
the dictionary going
and then the meeting is really quiet
like why are you asking those questions
well because i have the background i
don't know what i'm doing here but i'm
contributing
so that's exactly kind of you make a a
name for the office if you will
as to
why do we need to bring them in
and then once you get that
value spread out you will of at least
having you there
then people are successful coming more
and more at you for those topics whether
you have
the formal or the moral responsibility
over those topics um
so it is by contributing with some
understanding and knowledge
thank you edgar and thanks tori for for
jumping in too i i see trevor you asked
a question in the chat as well would you
want to ask that one live
yeah hi everyone
um i think my questions are
self-explanatory but um i'll go ahead um
so i wanted to find out a little bit
more about your
what's your data infrastructure like i
mean
so we're talking about
um databases
um
always all of that architecture
configured
um and you mentioned of course that your
trade your team
that you were you got some trading from
course era and this group in london i
wanted to get a little background into
what sort of training that was
and i mean the skill sets that you find
most important on your team
um even if there are soft skills and not
necessarily the hit skills
and also
justifying know if your data science
team is it a centralized or is it
distributed to um through different
units or departments
it's a lot
super yes so maybe i'll start with the
most fresh one and then you correct me
as we go backwards so when we started
the team with the data science group in
uh it was it was part of this
internal consulting group
so while it was centralized it was
serving the whole company
so it was deployed from our uh
consulting group but it was working with
purchasing or with aftermarket
controlling or with finance you know all
across the board
the key there was to
work
widely because the purpose was also to
elevate any place where we went to
and bring about the knowledge and the
tools and and the thinking uh methods
um
so
one back uh i think you're talking about
training
the training was very focused on the
analytical tools we wanted to leverage
because again with a shoestring budget i
didn't want to go pitch oh by the way
can i get this tool and that tool and
that tool there were other groups that
were significantly ahead of us in that
they found you know tools like data
mining tools or data aggregation tools
that weren't really ip per se i mean
we're not talking a full-blown
informatica solution we're talking about
something uh called alteryx and
authority designer and it's really uh
like sql in steroids where you just drag
and drop right just like you could do uh
like a shiny app
this thing helps you with that in that
it just kind of does the data mine
results so this this this specific
online
software training it wasn't really
just for alteryx but it had a bunch of
other topics really um
and i'm blanking on the name right now
but there is
so my whole inspiration from this came
from
a company in the uk that that back in
2014 2015
uh basically took tableau and some data
mining tools and created a school
i think it's called the data school
maybe you know i'm doing an ad for them
here
way way back
um and that was kind of the inspiration
is like you know
get the data drop in understand the
business get the data
make it stable
the the data mining piece that is
and then
the improvements should be made
measurable via some sort of
visualization tool
and not only because
it's that piece of satisfaction we're
looking at and for the stakeholder
satisfaction as well but in that
they continue to improve their processes
after we're gone so they continue to
measure the improvement and see where
they can tweak more for the benefits
so that was really kind of a
foundational inspiration for us to what
do we need to be learning
so this this this software
solution vendor in
in the uk was a good choice for that
super variety of topics
but with an accountability system that
you have to take a little quiz a little
test every so often
your manager would know about it
they would you know keep track of what
you're doing and the speed of your
progress things of that nature because
the training also it needs to have some
sort of
you know floor to it otherwise we just
hang out
which i tend to do
um
architecture wise we are a 75 year old
company so you can choose the name and
we have it
it's uh it was our old ip adage in that
business have the budget
came to it asked us to get something
done and we would just get it based on
what the business wanted
for that specific area not so much
holistically so now with our new cio is
more of a holistic view
what do we need to keep that serves
every single function and what can we
consolidate so now the pursuit is bad so
not that it's simplifying because we add
off-brand
cloud solutions you know architecture
gets more complex
um and i
admit i forgot the very first one before
architecture
so that was it that was it oh okay good
not bad thank you
all right
thank you trevor
um just a follow-up question because it
was an anonymous one on slido two was if
your team uses python r or julia and how
do you deploy data science solutions
so
um
when i was working with the team i was
also in the middle of getting a master's
in
in data analytics
and this was an interesting uh
combination between
the school of statistics at the
university and the college of
engineering so they both combined
classes so the college college of
engineers you know teaching everything
on python and all the ml and ai
applications but the uh
school statistics was more about
hypotheses and prove it and and and and
you know replicate it and we do it so i
was
one
foot in both
and for that reason i was very open to
the team using either
so i had a team member that was really
good with our markdowns and
his presentations and he was really good
at conveying that to the senior leaders
hiring us to work for them and another
one that was just very comfortable with
python and and
doing some nlp applications for our hr
team for example so
so we've used both
not julia
thank you
um manu i i see you asked a question in
the chat earlier as well do you want to
jump in and add a little more context on
that one too yeah sure uh hi everybody
um
i wanted to ask edgar
i do you have a data science approach
for for the after sales area for the dna
area parts
have you apply like
basket analysis uh
have you seen patterns in
in parts like collision repair or
maintenance parts i
that's my question thank you great
question i can tell you have a uh some
business context um
so yes we have um like i was saying
earlier now it has the center of
excellence that has
the big data group and they have uh
deployed some of their scientists across
the aftermarket
and we have some very interesting
applications in
heart replenishment um inventory volumes
um i i can't really
share the crown jewels uh deeply but
we applied to replenishment applied to
optimization of inventory levels applied
to um
timing of change over basically a
changeover for us means we have finished
the design of
a either a product or a or a vehicle or
a
an option in the vehicle
and we tested it
and it passes all of our testing and
then we communicate to our supply base
that we need some inventory from their
side because we're going to make this
now available for purchase and that's
the changeover point right where we say
it's no longer internal now it becomes
an outside looking
option or product
so
it's time to change it over so
on that timing we've also deployed some
interesting data science applications to
improve
with the volume right instead of saying
hey get 100 of this we're saying well
based on our data science approach you
need
twice that but in two different
locations versus just the one with our
footprint of
pdcs power distribution centers
we are having some interesting
applications of that as well
and uh some of the products that we
warranty as an aftermarket product as
well
so yes it's all over the place
great thank you very much
i see a great question that just came in
the slido as well
and it's i'll just read it to you it
says your work encompasses both low code
and code first communities
any ideas about how to build and
encourage mutual respect between those
two
groups oof um
i think the first is trust and and trust
in that
first one i would say that so i i was in
the business and i moved to their side
before the other side
before i move we were working on low
code
using outsystems
and
and it was really
i was part of a bunch of different very
stressful meetings
but
the last few mostly as an observer
and where i was able to pick up that our
i.t counterparts
were really stressed about something but
we were not picking up on it
and the stress was more about hey you
guys
you really haven't seen the full picture
on the other side
hey you guys we haven't really made a
good
effort on showing you what it looks like
but when you put something out there and
and you go from your development and you
pass your qa and you put it in
production
it's on us
and we want to know how much of your low
code application are you willing to
support saturdays and sundays
versus how much is on us and and then we
just start kind of like peeling the
onion and understanding really what was
driving their stressors right the guys
that are working on full-blown
development piece they know all those
pitfalls and they know they're going to
be on call and they know they don't have
the luxuries of
the analytics scenes that just you know
go off on the weekends as well with all
their stakeholders
and come back and deal with issues on
monday so there was a lot of
discovery and empathy built
seeking to learn what we didn't know
so from low code
you know you're moving boxes here and
there deploying yeah you make something
faster automatic and you know you get
pat on the back but that requires a
server
that requires information classification
that requires security around it that
requires a bunch of stuff from the
infrastructure side and the software
version inside you know and a few of the
things that we really didn't know about
and not because we didn't want to
because just because we didn't really
have the
foresight to ask what's driving your
stress what am i doing that's stressing
you
so the moment we started doing that we
started building bridges
and trust and and taking advice better
i hope that answers the question
thank you
what do you think um
were like the first initial questions
that led the team to say like okay now
it's time to build a data science team
or business problems they wanted to
solve
we identified things like
say we would look we're looking at
improving a process between two
key stakeholders in the company
and the
stakeholder that hire us
had more data and the data was 100
pointing at the other stakeholder being
at fault
right so
so we started going after well
why can't i have more of this data why
can't i do my own measurements can i get
more of this can i get more of that and
and and having that
unilateral um data push on you to make
things happen
it was really what what the driver was
why how do we do this how can we
uh take really a data driven approach
and not so much a which stakeholder is
more prepared approach
and and that that was those were some of
the kind of i would say failure modes
right when when you're trying to help
the company
but only one stakeholder is benefiting
from from your process improvement from
your analytics
it
it really makes no sense when you think
as a system right that's a system the
imbalance can come from either side not
just from the side with data
so that really drove us to think how do
we create a team that can
do this data based decision making
and what does your data science team
look like today is it made up of or
i guess how many data scientists or
versus data analysts
so my data science team
i think all but one have turned over
into the business
um
actually one of them
moved to a different area of uh daimler
into mercedes-benz cars
so it's kind of all in the family but um
but what happened is as a result of that
we had really deep and long
conversations with hr we had really deep
and long conversations with other areas
of the business
and they understood what they were
looking for so
job descriptions got better
the proliferation of like copy paste of
the skill sets that we were hiring for i
see them now everywhere
so now we have data scientists in the
aftermarket side in the marketing side
in finance for sure
and they might not be
labeling themselves as data scientists
but the practices and the conversations
we have when we get the data community
together
are very much of those that have the
same literacy and skill level
so now i can say we have them everywhere
they just look a little different
how do you get the data science
community together like do you have some
internal group
we do um
you know covered written a few things
among those what we used to do every
year we call it uh dtna that's the
occurring for the company in a
day-to-day and and purposely it's never
been a day it's always been two days and
everyone's thrown off because they're
highly quantitative and they're like
it's day the day but it's two days and
then that the conversation started but
we used to get everyone together and
my team was you know the driver of it
and we would get speakers and and
but then we would be all over the
company connected with people and
finding what is something that you want
to tackle what do you want to want a
working session you want to proliferate
knowledge in your area you want to you
know what can we do to assemble
interesting topics so so we would do
that
nowadays with one of my responsibilities
being the corporate data catalog
we hinge a lot on our data stewards
community
um
i have a couple of things i believe in
and like having latest and greatest
version of our software deploying
benefits and improvements and things
like that so those are drivers
for me to keep the community alive and
growing and using the data catalog as as
we aspire it to be so that's another
forum where we get
not only the data sciences but the data
thirsty let's say
and what is
what is the data catalog again it's uh
the brand i don't know if i should say
the brand or not but imagine that you
have
brazilian databases and schemas and all
this stuff right so when you're trying
to
uh
deploy your uh you know um
your your your r studio into a database
with the odbc
you kind of want to know what's in it
and instead of
just going in there and trying to read
all these columns and get samples of all
this data you can go to the catalog and
the catalog is a mix between maybe i'm
dating myself but the yellow pages and
yelp
right if structure is organized it has
content but it also has recommendations
because
over time as data gets copied or
federated or what have you
for your use case you might be looking
for a specific transformation of the
data
and if it's
yelped out you know you know that it's
been used for a prior case
or you can look at queries that have
been used to create a report for xyz
and that's the
the community piece of the data catalog
i just want to make sure i'm not missing
questions that people are asking because
i'm getting to ask a lot of mine
but um so feel free to to speak up live
too
but i'm curious to ask the audience too
i love that idea of the day-to-day or
two data days
i was wondering if other companies are
doing that too or do you have something
similar i'm sure kobe messes up some of
this but
you can put in the chat too
oh it sounds frank said target does i
know
our studio went to a conference one time
at disney and they had like a whole like
disney data conference for their
internal teams
um so i wonder if that's something
that's happening at more and more
companies now
yeah so we've had people who are from
intel's from
from universities you know who
speak with us um
we the last one i was just kind of
getting the
the conversations going with the ceo of
torque it's a autonomous um software
building company
and they just you know call it happen
but uh
but we always try to have this um kind
of
leading edge interesting topic right the
very first one was with intel and we
were talking about
edge computing and and kind of we had a
transformation going in all of our
manufacturing side so
it's always kind of nice and cohesive
thank you i see another question that
just came in was i've seen in your
profile that you're a lean process
manager just a curious question how does
lean integrate with data science
it's very interesting because from lean
and and six sigma it was about what's
being
first of all is a process what is the
best way it needs to be and lean you're
always in recovery afterwards
because you think about data flows and
transformations and the stages of of
data so if your data is not reliable
your analysis might have lots of holes
in it right so that's kind of i think
the first leap of faith between
data and data science and when i was
coaching some of these themes
i'll give you an example we were working
in one of our manufacturing sites and we
were working on a
on a question of interest
at material handling and receiving
and um
and it was like a lien driven approach
right are we doing the right things for
the for the right size
but then we went into the quantitative
piece of it
and
everything was kind of out of whack it
just didn't look like anything right so
i was telling the team why don't you
look at the data acquisition piece right
we have three shifts and turns out that
some of the people in in one shift were
using you know
four or five out of a 12
shortage
recent codes
and then along comes the second shift
and you know it's always the most
stressful one time wise
so they were dumping everything into one
and then the third shift was like
you know sometimes we're like well we'll
just leave it the first shift to do it
right so you're supposed to be capturing
the data of the recent codes of why
you're having shortages
in 12 different categories
in three different moments in time
and they were totally uneven
they were they weren't really driving
the learning we needed
right so
that's where
lean behavior leads into the data
quality which leads into the data
science analysis possibility without the
data being skewed already by acquisition
can i ask you if i'm just imagining if i
was a new data science leader joining
the call um
what is some advice that you'd give to
someone who's maybe like just made that
move into a leadership role and is just
starting to build out their team
i would say challenge yourself to be as
smart and clever as your team is
um
people are asking me you know you
already have a masters or you want
another masters
and trying to do this very smart thing
and attract very smart people to create
a team and if i don't understand and i
don't expand my mental model i can't
meet them at the same at the same spot
right
so being intellectually curious and
not that you have to know more because
you're the boss but it's so that
they find your pursuit
and and and they find that their
knowledge is is
it's valuable to the point where you
don't mind spending a couple nights a
week learning more and understanding
more and having much much more
depth in the conversations
it's it's not it's not easy and i
remember i did this to my own boss where
i said look we're going to start working
on this project
i'm going to come out and tell you it's
going to take me two months
i said and you're going to say great
and i'm going to go away laughing and
say hey i have no idea what i'm talking
about and he's like really would you do
that i said well not me but you're gonna
have more people working with this team
eventually different leaders
so i at the end of the day um he ended
up joining me and taking a python class
with
and we did homework together and we
challenged each other but he was
understanding that in this new
you know this era of data currency
really the throughput conversations we
had had nothing to do with just pure
effort
right there's so many more variables
that go through it and he was he was um
you know humble and wise enough at the
same time to pick that up and turn out
the great role model for me for people
in his
peer group
awesome hey frank i see you unmuted i
didn't want to
start talking if you were about to ask
something
it took 52 minutes but i think i'm ready
edgar you had you talked about recording
defects
um have you or your group tried to do
any kind of automated root cause
analysis
which
from from my observations has been one
of the
more really challenging date
i don't even know if it's data science
like data science tasks that is very
operational still
um
and it's hard like it's hard and i'm
just kind of curious if you guys have
have taken on any of those challenges
and if so um i don't know you got any
advice
we didn't we didn't really get to it um
in the wild we do have um
six sigma folks at every factory
but we don't have the telemetry we're
required to just deploy those
variable measurements
steadily if you will
it would require really a a heavy load
on that um we are making our our
factories much more modern to where
now um let's say a torque gun speaking
to us and it's letting us know when it's
in and without range or out of range and
we have now built-in standard procedures
to capture that and the operator will do
the tweaking
but it's going to take much more
footprint for us to get there and have
that automatically built into into iot
i
uh let me know if you agree here but uh
a lot of data science and what people
think of data science is is born and
raised in technology companies
right all the silicon valley companies
and
operations and supply chain is still
catching up right like we're getting
there but we need that foundation first
right like we need the smart factories
um to have data to do more of the data
science model building pattern
recognition yeah and you should see me i
wish i could i could share much more
about it but imagine that
not only the
the signal but also getting into well
this is a time series type of signal
and the people get it people not get it
is your cloud ready for it and are you
getting the signals of the event before
or after or during the continuum and is
it getting a super expensive stack and
absolutely i think the the really they
really the topic should be driven about
the the the footprint right of of of the
connected factory or the connected truck
and i very frequently ask uh much
brighter people and myself when they
talk about the connected truck
i say from zero to 100 how connected is
the truck
or the vehicle for that matter right
is it a hundred percent like can i tell
the wear and tear on the on the hinges
as i open the door and close it
or can i tell you know the the damage to
the lock mechanism because somebody
slammed the door
or what happens to my
my my harnesses connected right are they
just
more shaping out of movement or what's
going on it really is not as deep as as
we think it is when it comes to
connected anything
that's that's just the truck itself how
about the network that the truck is in
right is it bouncing is it up
you know the signal is it's
the fidelity is it going to the data
acquisition
does it need transformation how much
transformation and is the transformation
automatic yeah it's it's a beautiful
challenge but
um the torque on is a good example where
the the thing talks to yourself and it's
in real time
uh and it's the best case when your own
operator knows that that's happening
right it's like driving and hearing a
noise you know you should pull
over i appreciate it yeah nice out here
thank you okay
i see trevor you just asked one other
question do you still code and build
models
for fun but mostly at the level where i
can bracket my children
love it
i have a an 11 year old girl that i went
to inspiring stem and a
seven-year-old boy that you know i also
would like to have inspiring to stand
so
we'll see they have the final word
how do
how do you go about inspiring them
by showing them that it's hard work but
by also showing them all the rewards
that come with it
not in a braggadocio's way but in the
joy that i have doing the job
that's great
manu i i see you just asked a question
around diversity do you want to jump in
or you want me to read that
uh sure i i i guess mr gallo speak
spanish i i i think he's from mexico
i'm sorry for speaking spanish right now
but but i want you to ask a question
about how do you approach diversity in a
data science team
well diversity is a very interesting
topic because um it is it has so many
lenses and dimensions to it
so for me i still remember one of the
first people that i hired um
we had an exercise with our hr team and
they do the personality profile and we
use disk
so i am a d and a high i and he is an s
and a c
so he asks me
he's looking at was like why did you
hire me
i go
exactly for that reason
he's like
and he took a moment to go oh it's a
balancing thing right so that's exactly
what it is for me
it's all about balancing
in in balancing of perspectives of
upbringing of
you know
age and gender and style and approach to
life basically because
data science is curiosity and data
science could be biased or not biased
right so
when i'm assuming a certain condition to
an analysis somebody else with totally
different background will come up from
from from nowhere and say
it doesn't happen like that in the u.s
maybe in mexico it does but here's
totally different and that's kind of the
trick for me to
not only
pursue the the the the diversity in the
team but also almost make you a
non-negotiable
right if if you have just right-handed
people
you're gonna do just right-handed people
stuff
as a
bit of a follow-up there how do you
focus on diversity when hiring
and how do you make that a part of the
hiring process so now we have a a kind
of a newer process where um
you don't get to see anything
but answers to the attributes you're
looking for so you have no idea
if this individual is from mars or
you know from uh you know from the ocean
you just know that they're alive and
they break air and they are interested
in your job and that's how you go about
really seeking what what is the best
skill set combination that you want
um it's it's now rolled out with our hr
business partners and and it's i my
opinion is working well
because it really takes everything out
of the
first impression sort of thing for me at
least because if you really just dive
into
the fun of the work the technical topics
what you've done before why why are you
pursuing this here now
so that's that uh
it's kind of with with help if you will
but it's uh
it's been working well for me
awesome
edgar i know we're getting to the top of
the hour here so i just want to ask if
anybody has follow-up questions or wants
to connect with you is the best way
through linkedin yes absolutely
i'm a little slow on that you know got a
lot on the plate but don't think i'm
ghosting anyone
it's just a little slow
rob do you want to if you want to share
edgar's or tyler edgar's linkedin in the
chat that would be awesome
and one last question for you then i'm
trying to go through all the recordings
and keep a list of these too that i'll
share with everyone but are there
certain books or podcasts that you'd
recommend that some of us check out
uh wow yes but nothing maybe data
sciencey um
the one i'm super hooked on right now is
darknet diaries
totally has everything to do with my
current gig and
understanding what our information
security officers do and
it's super fun
i'll have to check it out
well thank you so much edgar for joining
us and sharing your insights with
everyone really appreciate your time
absolutely super happy to do it and
thank you everyone for your questions
and um looking forward to
seeing you all again
thank you all so much for joining and um
if anybody has feedback or suggestions
for future sessions too i did just put a
anonymous um google form in there as
well we'd love to see you all next week
same time same place have a great rest
of the day
you